we can see that
putin's army is now starting to target
civilians it may be an act of military
desperation
but i think by all accounts this amounts
to a war crime these are targeting
civilians killing women and children
targeting housing
this is uh
not acceptable by any standard and of
course eventually uh putin will have to
uh uh
will have to answer for the crimes he is
currently committing
yeah that will all play out but let's
concentrate on what's happening right
now you've seen the aerial attacks in
ukraine today the ukrainian president
reiterated his call for a no-fly zone
over ukraine you may have seen
journalists asking the british prime
minister boris johnson about that and he
said no nato member countries are
considering this as an option
why not ukraine is under attack from on
air and as you said
civilians are being targeted
well we have to remember that just in
the past few days there have been
massive shifts in policy throughout
europe um uh
last thursday for many it was not
imaginable that germany would actually
provide arms or or let other countries
re-export their arms they now are
supplying arms themselves and are going
to be increasing their defense spending
to two percent of gdp
uh in the beginning it was just the
baltics poland a few other countries of
course the uk the us that were supplying
arms to ukraine now we are being joined
by more and more countries uh this is a
very positive sign the ukrainians are
fighting for our values the values of
freedom democracy and the rule of law
and putin is fighting to recreate an
empire to subjugate a neighboring
country
and to stamp out democracy in the rule
of law so it is by all means a justified
fight of defense and we in in in the
west in democratic countries have a
great responsibility to help them in any
and all ways that we can so financial uh
help has been flowing for many many
quarters including the entire european
union of course many member states in
addition to that countries outside of
the european union
military aid is also extremely important
what we can see that that the ukrainian
defenders are
courageous i think does not even come
close to describing what they are doing
uh but they are they are they're they
are defending their country or they're
defending all of our values uh and it
shows also i think the desperation of
the uh of the russian army of putin's
army that it has to resort to such
brutal uh targeting of civilians yes as
you said it's brutal the ukrainians are
courageous and they have our admiration
but they do need more than that you talk
about policy changes
from countries uh from the eu from nato
as a collective do you see there being a
policy shift on a no-fly zone would you
support that because we are seeing
residential buildings orphanages
hospitals being targeted do you support
a shift in policy
um
the question is um how far things will
get so i think there is a certain
hesitancy on behalf of many countries to
have an open
nato russia conflict we currently do not
have an open nato russia conflict we
have many countries among the many nato
member states providing arms providing
all kinds of support to the ukrainian
army so does russia have to reach nato
borders for there to be a no-fly zone
because as president zelinski points out
that will be too late if ukraine falls
russia is on nato member country's
border a no-fly zone has to come into
force before then doesn't it
well
russia already is on nato country
borders so russia is on the border of my
country on the border of estonia and the
border of lithuania on the border of
poland
already today
this is unprecedented territory where we
currently are the important thing is
that we in western democracies both in
the eu and in nato work and stick
together and right now we have a
fantastic fantastic cooperation uh there
are decisions being taken which were
unthinkable uh even a week ago uh we
have to see how things develop but the
important thing here is just continue
sticking together because putin has been
trying to drive a wedge
between us between democratic countries
that is part of his strategy all along
uh he has gotten actually the exact
opposite he has gotten a coming together
of countries uh ever firmer ever firmer
ever firmer if we look at the economic
sanctions which have been adopted these
are extremely and they will be extremely
devastating to the russian economy
cutting off the russian central bank
from funding means effectively
taking out most of putin's
foreign cash reserves so that government
is not going to have the money uh to uh
to pay for its social services to pay
for wages but we pay for everything
eventually already now we're seeing in
moscow and other cities runs on the
banks we're seeing a huge uh spike in
the in the cost of the of the ruble the
stock exchange has been closed there
already is uh are great great
difficulties significant impact but that
will take a while to take effect if you
like because the idea being that those
close to putin need to feel that the
russian people need to feel that and
that all takes time as you quite rightly
pointed out russia is on your border on
latvia's border and we have heard
experts warn that look if russia takes
ukraine you are vulnerable countries
like latvia are vulnerable because he'll
come for you next
uh well
putin is not only fighting against
ukraine putin is fighting against
democracy and in that sense he's
fighting against all of our democracies
he does not believe in the idea of a
nation state or the right of
self-determination he is said as much
explicitly in the case of ukraine he
wants to recreate an empire so an attack
on ukraine essentially is an attack on
democracy as such so of course uh i
think all of us are in for a long in a
very difficult road
this is the beginning of that and it's
the complete confrontation of uh putin
with the west what we are in the process
of doing and i think it's correct is a
complete isolation of putin's regime and
these are not to be underestimated the
various sanctions they are biting
already the various seizures of property
of the various tycoons uh closely
affiliated with with russia we see
already inside russian television hosts
being uh aghast at how can their italian
villa be taken from them well the fact
is it has been taken from them and more
will be taken and this is what we have
to understand it is putin's attack on uh
western democracy we have to stay strong
stay united here and we're also doing
the the right thing within nato we are
reinforcing
all of the eastern flank from the baltic
down to the black sea there are more uh
nato forces in the baltic countries also
in my country than there were just two
weeks ago there's more uh uh
there's more soldiers there's more
military hardware uh technology so this
buildup on our soil will continue uh we
just made a decision over the three the
upcoming three years to further increase
our spending on defense up to two and a
half percent were over 2.2 by 2.3
percent we'll be upping the ante there
so we're not just a consumer of security
we are also paying ourselves and many
countries are doing this actually
throughout nato so
we are becoming a true uh uh a a true um
force also at an individual country
level and remember the european union
has now taken a decision to collectively
fund arms for ukraine this has never
been before so even the eu is coming
onto the global stage not only as an
economic
but also ever more growing as a as a
military power so we have incredible
strength on our side
the economy of the west is income
incomparably larger than russia's the
combined military strength makes
russia's military seem actually rather
quite small so we needn't be afraid of
our own power we have to build on that
power because in order to speak with
putin putin only understands the
language of power so more strength more
investment more support for ukraine is
the way to get a putin to start to
consider things different yeah i think
it was a british prime minister boris
johnson who pointed out earlier today if
putin hoped that nato would get smaller
it's actually only getting bigger and
stronger prime minister while i have you
one final question if i may and this is
about the um
refugee crisis that will undoubtedly be
created is you know it started as a
result of what is happening in ukraine
uh what is latvia doing to help those
who want to cross the border from
ukraine
into your country
all right well we don't have a direct
land border those refugees are primarily
coming from poland lithuania into latvia
we have of course our ontarian ministry
has an entire system set up to accept
refugees but what we're seeing is a
fantastic
groundswell of volunteer support so we
have local communities individuals
already taking ukrainians into their
homes into their families feeding them
helping them we have we're adapting our
laws so these people would legally have
a right to work uh bringing them into
the healthcare system etc etc so from
the government side and especially from
the private individual side we're seeing
an outpouring of support and actually
the only difficult that we have is that
we have so many people wanting to help
that we're having difficulty making sure
everyone has something to do so there is
a tremendous groundswell of support for
ukraine people companies are donating
funds so money is going to the ukrainian
government to them to keep up the war
effort and the economy as such we're
continuing sending humanitarian supplies
military supplies fuel medicines
everything uh there's a there's
tremendous support in our country and we
also um will continue in the spain
closely coordinating with our neighbors
with our friends in the european union
and with our allies in nato